hello everybody and welcome to rational
science directly from Frankfurt Germany
got a good day today great day we're
going to be uh answering some questions
regarding um
we have a couple interesting questions
one about the ether the other one about
the slit experiment I'll deal with that
at the end but
um the main subject today main course is
uh numbers what in the world are numbers
does anybody know out there and but
before we get to that let's start with
our Extinction segment and the subject
today that I've got is this uh issue
about the trans going on you know the is
there a trans Revolution going on
you know I mean uh the subject matter is
on the news every day now and we're not
talking about just like one article like
it's everywhere you know even in the
courts okay and so here we have um one
article that came out says the
transgender girl will not attend her
high school graduation after Mississippi
judge denies emergency plea to permit
her to go dressed as a girl and that's a
part of the complaint that they filed in
court uh the so-called uh this
individual uh wants to remain anonymous
apparently
and he she whatever uh once addressed as
a girl and they say no you're a boy and
you gotta dress as a boy
and so that's one issue that's going on
and here you have another article that
kind of goes on the opposite side of
that and this has to do with this
organization called Do no harm it's a
non-profit and it's a somewhat
criticized because people are saying
look you're you're really doing politics
and you're uh you know shielding it
under the label that it's a non-profit
uh and it has to do well it has to do
with several things but uh they
mentioned as an example uh this uh
individual by the name of Cole and says
that
um uh she had uh
she removed her breasts at the age of 15
and then she changed her mind but it was
too late it was a mistake and so uh
they're using her as a poster a boy
poster girl I guess I don't know
uh for this trans stuff saying you know
at least that you should not uh you know
have make decisions when you're a
teenager right because you might repent
you might and you can't take it back
whatever you do there
okay so the question is you know are we
in some kind of what I call the
trans-revolution you know uh we're going
uh we have a problem with uh humanity is
there a problem with humans are we uh
changing uh the way people are born or
or or is this just a fad okay and here
you have uh three individuals there they
transition from male to female and
they're winning a lot of uh contests out
there boxing kickboxing
um biking uh running swimming you know
you got them in everywhere in every
sport now and is this just a way of
making money you know like uh you're a
boy you change your sex and suddenly you
beat all the girls is that what that's
all about
and yeah a lot of the girls don't like
uh uh the fact that they're competing
against guys right
and so there's this debate out there
whether they should or they shouldn't
uh you know people also want to be named
with the proper pronouns and so on and
other folks say look you know uh
whatever you think you are that's your
problem I'm gonna I'm gonna call you
what I think I see you know if you think
you're a monkey you know you want me to
treat you like a monkey you know that's
that's your problem it's like you know
I'm gonna
see a boy or a girl and that's what I'm
gonna deal with but if you think you're
a monkey or a cow or whatever a tree
well you know it's like that's your
problem you know so they have these
discussions going on
uh it's it's quite a bit in the news
um and so the question is is this just
the fat or is this for real is there
something going on with Humanity okay
that's that's I guess the the bottom
line question right
okay so here we have uh uh a situation
especially in uh
you know an article that came out in
sports and it's got to do with women who
are making money you know and it's like
they don't go to the uh mines and work
you know underneath the ground and pull
out the coal they don't go to the
shipyards and start unloading bags you
know it's not the kind of work they're
doing they all want to be models and
actresses and make lots of money you
know and so here uh they have this uh
swimsuit competition at uh the uh uh
swimsuit search right Sports Illustrated
uh branch and you have all these girls
and they're applying it I'm talking
about thousands of girls and all the you
know they they all want to compete
because they want to make money and what
is that that's the entertainment
business right you have all these uh
some cute girls you know they have great
bodies and you know you probably want to
take a snapshot of them you have some
like the other ones you know a little
tubby there and uh maybe you know Eskimo
might confuse them and uh for something
Harpoon at them you know so uh I don't
know
um is this all about a fad is this about
entertainment is is there something
changing in humanity that you know that
um
is affecting our genes or whatever okay
that's the issue and again I'm I'm uh
saying is this just entertainment or
just a fad going on is this going to
blow over or is this a trend that's
going to continue
and
um it was the Roman days you know this
was entertainment in those days uh they
called it bread and circus right they
would go and see the uh Gladiator die on
us on you know on the arena and they
loved it they thought it was great and
it lasted many years okay so this was
entertainment in those days no TV right
uh no radio
and uh we have new entertainment these
days and this is maybe what uh it looks
like I'm seeing for the last humans on
Earth uh we live in the age of leisure
age of entertainment you know a lot of
stuff we have today is geared is
um the context is entertainment you know
what do we use robots Ai and Bots aside
from taking jobs from humans right well
a lot of that has to do with the
entertainment industry right all these
things video games TV movies music it's
all entertainment all Leisure so the
guy's at home he's got nothing else to
do he's got time to kill right he goes
through all this stuff they go into
diets you know whether they're vegans or
uh you know or they eat meat right
whichever travel Sports uh sex as you
just saw you know these girls that uh
they want to make money why because
there's a lot of money in the
entertainment business they want to hit
it big you know in the big time
um and again so the question is is this
just and we have fads like piercing
tattoos veganism and so on you know is
this all related to uh Leisure to
entertainment
is that we have so much time on our
hands uh compared to like uh the
Neanderthals you know in the old days
they had to go get up and uh go and Hunt
if they wanted to live one more day and
we don't seem to have that problem it's
like you know you just go to a store and
somehow magically things appear in you
on the shelves and all you got to do is
figure out how to make money to go out
there and buy it you know so
you know think about that anyways here
are the trends and I call them the trans
Trends okay it doesn't include only
trans it's got all the letters in the
alphabet there but uh there seems to be
a growth of people who
um have a different version of sex than
we what we were used to okay and you can
see the numbers have been rising
and again is this just a fad or is this
real
you know that's a question you got to
look at because if this is real it might
be telling us something about Humanity
about you know what's happening the
babies that are being born
uh maybe they're being born when the
woman is too late or the guy is too late
like they're in their 50s or 40s or
whatever that's one issue the other one
is that
you know we have this Society uh where
we're crowded into cities and for those
of you who are familiar with Calhoun's
experiments you know what I'm talking
about you have that density dependent
birth rate uh then you have the issue of
you know founders effect we all come
from the same
uh great great grandfathers that were
alive uh 200 years ago and those came
from great great grandfathers that came
200 300 years earlier so you know if you
look at Humanity we were like what 300
million at the beginning of the
Christian era it's a calculation they
have and today we are 8 billion we all
come from those people in fact we don't
come from all of them because not all of
them survived so assuming we came from
half of them that even reduces our gene
pool
significantly right even further
so here we are today and we're having
these problems the question is
is this an issue of having lost our
genetic diversity which we have by the
way you know anyone who you marry today
is your brother or your sister from a
genetically point of view genetic point
of view
okay another matters related matters uh
here we have China and they're worried
about the fact that they don't have
enough population they have 1.4 billion
people and they say we want more yeah
the problem is uh China's not growing at
the same Pace it was in the past and so
they're a little concerned about that
because when they project that into the
future they realize there's going to be
problems okay and here you have the
article it says China launches project
to build New Era marriage childbearing
culture
so the Chinese will launch a pilot
projects in more than 20 cities okay
where they're going to stimulate
marriage and childbearing uh the the
project intends you know to encourage
women to marry and have children and
they claim that many women have been put
off having more children or any at all
due to the expense of child care and
having to stop their careers with gender
discrimination still a key hurdle okay
so you can see uh what the problems are
or the way they see it and they want to
cure that they say we got to put the
right conditions for women to have
children
and you know it's not only China Japan
Russia United States Europe in general
everybody's having problems but here's
the article
that summarize that pretty much says
forget sex drought the real reason the
birth rate is dropping is much more
mundane lower birth rates and falling
fertility is a worldwide phenomena
absolutely
okay this is something that's happening
worldwide every country almost in fact
every country in the world I think there
are no exceptions there's no country
where uh fertility rate in other words
the birth rates are rising you're very
worried about population decline far
right leaders such as uh so and so's are
explicit about the need to replace their
populations a certain number of babies
have to be born in order to support the
Aging population so that's a question of
Social Security I guess they're worried
about that a little bit right
and then it says uh uh if this doesn't
happen we need immigrants
aha okay so uh are we gonna be importing
people just for the sake of populating
of crowding the cities is that what it's
all about so that they can uh maintain
the old population that used to live
there right
anyways uh some of the problems they uh
that they say cause women not to have
children or
couples not to have children really is
housing too expensive young people are
living with their parents uh women don't
want to go there long bring up a child
in poverty all by themselves uh get and
remember a kid is a uh an anchor you
know uh if you're stuck with a kid well
you can't really move around as easily
you know and so that's one of the things
that is in people's minds
affordable child care flexible working
practices you know does the workforce
need to adjust to accommodate women and
their uh female problems you know like
having babies taking care of babies and
so on or how is that going to be solved
right people may be prioritizing other
goals that's another issue again what is
it mostly uh Leisure right it's uh
entertainment traveling career right and
education but a lot of that again is uh
like I say it's got to do with uh the
entertainment business everybody's into
entertainment we have quite a bit of
time on our hands today because we don't
have to go out there until the land and
produce the food it's like you know you
punch your card work eight hours go home
and now you have all this time another
eight hours before you go to sleep for
eight hours right you have these eight
hours and we use them for leisure
primarily
and that's the issue uh I think that's
why it's become big business and why a
lot of companies are in that business
right because it's uh whichever Branch
you get into you know whether it's
television modeling whatever you get
into music art it um it has an outlet
today
someone will buy it
okay uh and the related matters we have
some fake news you know here we had for
several weeks uh Russian forces Retreat
you Reign advancing uh Ukrainian repels
attacks and so on and what was it I
think uh today they claimed that uh the
Wagner group together with the Russian
troops they took over this uh wreck of a
town known as bakmut okay so uh yeah I
guess uh
if they took over I don't know what
they've conquered there but lots of
people got killed in in the process
right and so it's like you get fake news
because you're saying okay it looks like
the Russians are retreating they're
going back they're being slaughtered and
then suddenly they say oh by the way uh
the city fell in the Russian hands so
you don't want to explain you know how
do you explain these things uh how does
that work
um a lot of fake news uh regarding war
and again it's just because they want to
create public opinion to support it and
so you got to be careful uh what side
you root for because there's
misinformation on both sides okay it's
uh what I call military information the
military-onlyles certain type of
information to go up because that's
important for their strategies right so
my recommendation don't take any side
but that's just me I learned my the hard
way not to get into politics and that is
politics right how you handle
information
okay hear more fake news okay this is uh
it gives you an idea what kind of news
we receive and why you should have to be
careful with whatever you read out there
so as U.S military thought it killed a
senior Al Qaeda leader in a drone strike
but some officials are now saying they
may have made a mistake looks like they
killed a little farmer out there right
and they said we are no longer confident
we kill the senior uh Al-Qaeda official
to win official total post another
official said though we believe the
strike did not kill the original Target
we believe the person to be Al-Qaeda
turns out the um
white hat white helmets from the U.N
they went out there to the field almost
immediately after the guy was killed and
everybody in the uh in the uh region and
the town said that they had identified
the individual with his name his
profession and apparently he was just a
farmer or whatever guy's always been a
farmer he's never had any political
activities he's never had any
affiliation with armed groups
so uh I guess they went in there and
just killed someone and they say oh
we're sorry oops
it's unbelievable they can do whatever
they want thank God they don't shoot you
down because you know they they'll put
out as an excuse oh we're sorry we
killed the wrong guy
that's the status that's the state of
the world today okay
okay uh let's move on to number what is
a number okay and probably the best way
to handle that this uh issue is uh
through history you know let's start
there
um numbers usually are related to
amounts and quantities
and so the question is uh did we invent
this just a hundred years ago a thousand
years ago maybe 2 000 years ago how far
back do we go to get to numbers to to
people understanding that uh the notion
of quantities is it's uh like you know a
hundred thousand years ago how far back
should we go
and here's a at least some of the
evidence that we have today
um uh anything related to amounts and
quantities that have been logged somehow
okay maybe the first numbering systems
you could call them and here you have
the the bombo bone okay I think it's uh
nearsouth Africa or somewhere in there
in the south southern part of Africa
somewhere in the continent right that's
one bone it's got some marks in it and
it uh some people think it's got to do
with the moon cycles other with uh
female Administration and so on so we
don't really know
um you can only guess and theorize
wolfbone something similar marks on a on
a bone and yeshango Bone also also with
marks so all these uh are uh examples
that maybe are Way Way Back forefathers
you know they probably Mark some of
these things for whatever reasons and it
looks like they already relate had that
these marks had something to do with
Counting
uh closer to our days about 2500 years
before Christ we're talking about maybe
four or five thousand six thousand years
ago uh they had the Abacus okay and
that's a counting device right there's
the soundness tablet
um they found uh they dated it to about
300 BC and again it's like uh Abacus
um on a
scroll or Papyrus or something
and then in the Americas we had this uh
quippu which is a um a device that has
knots and these people the especially
the elites you know the people who were
going to be the uh professors the
teachers the doctors you know they they
knew how to handle this uh they had
these knots and they could count with
these knots it's especially it's a type
of Abacus also you know but it's uh made
with these uh ropes okay and so um we
learn how to count and we learned about
amounts and quantities a long time ago
okay now uh numbers numbers they came uh
they came later but then the question is
how do they handle these things if if
numbers came later how was this handled
originally you know and here you have
um uh one way you know the that you have
you can relate to this is through trade
okay because people did begin to trade
at some point in the Neolithic and you
know if you gave them a cow what did he
give you an exchange well maybe he gave
you Barney I don't know but uh what if
uh you had this uh common coin that
everybody accepted right and then at
that point you would say okay uh just
give me so many coins uh for the cow or
whatever you gave them and you know you
could do something with those coins and
that had to give you also an idea of
amounts and quantities okay because you
wouldn't tell the cow for Just Two
grains of uh of uh corn you know he had
to ask for something else and so here's
uh the notion we have today that or at
least this is the evidence the hard
evidence okay we have coins uh from uh
says they're the shekel from Mesopotamia
okay and a first known form of currency
remembers nearly five thousand years ago
some kind of currency we don't really
know what but the earth is known mints
okay the the actual coin right uh they
did to about 600 650 uh BC Asia Minor in
Lydia and uh here you had uh the uh main
guy who we got those from uh creases and
there you have them swimming in Gold you
know he's uh he was uh known to be very
rich okay he had these troops and
everything he fought against the uh
Persians and lost
and Cyrus the Great you know took him as
a prisoner there's two versions of that
they say that Cyrus named him as his
right hand man or put him as a governor
and the other version is that he burned
him alive I tend to think uh to like the
second version I think that's what he
probably did okay but anyways this is
when coins started out okay
at least a solid evidence we do have
these coins in our hands today okay but
uh that was 600 years before BC right
before Christ but here you have uh Ken
maidis and uh he's known as the guy with
the golden touch right he uh he had the
Midas touch and he touched his daughter
and turned her into gold
and they say he lived around 2000 BC
okay now the reason for that is that uh
the Midas touch right is that he was a
very rich guy apparently at least that's
what the mythology says right uh
apparently there was some kind of some
King 2 000 years uh or these 1400 years
before uh creases right that already had
lots of money now did he have gold coins
is the question and the answer is
probably not but then
how do they handle these things what
kind of what was the uh amount did they
have a pile of sand you know and they
say okay we'll weigh it against your
pile of gold uh nuggets or whatever this
was the issue how did they do transact
or silver right for that matter how did
they do these transactions and obviously
they they gave silver less value than
gold which means that they understood
the difference or the uh commonality of
how much gold it was versus how much
silver I guess right
and but we have
um
a specific
a piece of evidence okay and here it is
is the Code of Hammurabi and that dates
to almost 2 000 years ago about the time
of uh King Midas a little later but more
or less and we have the code okay we
have the code today it's about 280 plus
288 lines I think it is of how people
should behave or else right and you can
see there um they talk about money
silver gold you know money money checo
and the question what were these uh were
they coins we don't have any evidence
that they had coins but then they had to
have some peace
that was like standard because we talked
about the shekel I guess you're you're
talking about uh you know some unit of
some kind right but we don't have these
apparently we don't have them today I
haven't found it but maybe maybe it is
somewhere they have the late shekels you
know uh the Hebrews they had shekels as
well okay but those came after they came
like 600 years before Christ which is
about the time of Lydia's uh crisis uh
coins uh we know that there were coins
600 maybe maybe even 700 years before
Christ but the quest is were there coins
minted coins 2 000 years before Christ
that's the issue okay but uh all this
points to the fact that we had a notion
of amounts and we needed those Notions
in order to make a transaction
commercial transactions trade right so
um uh we were aware of that but then
that's got to have some kind of
numbering system behind it
how do you have my mounts without having
some kind of notion of numbers okay of
quantities okay so I don't know how they
handled it then maybe a little making uh
some marks with uh unclaimed tablets
saying look three three of these that's
four of yours or whatever or these three
represent one cow or whatever it was you
know
uh but yeah that's I guess the first
Notions we had of that okay so um what
is the uh discipline that deals with
numbers well it's known as mathematics
okay mathematics is an area of knowledge
that includes the topics of what numbers
okay mathematics deals with numbers it's
not chemistry specifically right uh it's
not literature it's not art no it's
known as mathematics formulas and
related structure shapes and the space
of and the shapes and and the spaces in
which they are contained well I'll
disagree that because mathematics does
not deal with shapes at all okay they
deal with quantities not with shapes and
quantities and their uh changes okay
there is no General consensus among
mathematicians about a common definition
for their academic discipline so here we
have all these mathematicians okay and
uh they say I'm a mathematician oh okay
what do you do well I don't know because
we never defined our discipline
okay in a branch of mathematics which is
probably where we should start because
um uh we're talking about amounts at the
basic level at the numbers right when we
created numbers okay and it looks like
this it says what is arithmetic that's
what it's about right arithmetic is this
uh Tiny Branch I guess you could say or
the beginning Branch okay and it's uh
says arithmetic d uh is the branch of
math right that deals with the study of
numbers okay so that's where we start
arithmetic using various operations on
them okay so operations are separate
from numbers okay and it says basic
operations are of uh math or addition
subtraction and so on right okay so
we're all familiar with that
okay so we're talking about arithmetic
when we're dealing with numbers
primarily we're talking about arithmetic
okay so here um
here's a discipline that within math
that deals with numbers we call it uh
arithmetic okay but then what is a
number what do we what do we what do we
mean when we say number what is a number
and so uh this is a definition you'll
find in the Wikipedia and it's the
perfect super duper scientific
definition of the word number so please
pay attention a number is a mathematical
object
uh-huh
used to what count measure and label
okay especially keep an eye on the words
count and measure okay that's what
they're going to use this mathematical
object whatever that is right so what is
a mathematical logic oh this is from the
Wikipedia so you'll find it in there
it's an abstract concept an object is a
concept okay includes numbers great
so we have a mathematics a number is a
mathematical object which is a number
great we have a circular definition
known as a synonym right
uh abstract concept what is abstract
well abstraction conceptual process I
like that so we have a concept concept
that's what it is a conceptual concept
that's what an abstract concept is it's
a conceptual process right what is a
concept it's an abstract idea I like
that concept is an abstract abstract is
a concept and
concept is an abstract absolutely love
that abstract idea what's an idea well
the result of thought
uh-huh
okay yeah I hope you you're following I
hope you can take the test on Friday
okay what is thought conscious process
and what is consciousness awareness of
existence
I hope you now know what a number is
okay and I like the fact that the the
only part that's probably true is just
the
definitional issue right numbers should
be distinguished from numerals okay
numerals are different than numbers okay
numeral is the little symbol that we use
to represent the number it could be a
letter you know like letter A that
represent the number or a variable or
whatever right and uh the symbols used
to represent numbers
okay so uh I hope you know what a number
is uh now okay
okay so what's the issue the issue is
that uh they want to focus the
mathematicians uh don't want to just
stay with
um with
um
counting they want to also go into
measuring there's a difference between
counting and measuring counting you
count units okay measure
uh you know you can have uh fractions
you know decimals and so on so measuring
is a little different than counting
right it's not the same
um activity okay and so here you have uh
the the question is
um is a number an issue of counting or
is it an issue of measuring okay are are
we counting units or are we measuring
something that goes beyond the unit or
halfway between two units okay so we
have a difference if if number refers to
Counting then it ain't measuring and
vice versa we need to Define that word
number correctly and we have to find out
if it's counting or measuring and what
they did is they put everything in and
it's counting it's measuring it's
labeling the whole thing
and this creates a little bit of problem
right because
when you you know cover every base
you lose uh uh information you don't
gain everything you lose it because you
put it all in there and people get
confused is it about measuring is it
about counting okay
and so what are we going to argue here
well we're going to say that it's only
County it's got nothing at all to do
with measure okay so here's uh County
okay what is number it's a verb it's not
announced the verb it's a verb to count
okay what are you doing you're uh moving
the finger up and down right one two
three and what you're doing is
increasingly you know giving a new label
to the new amount to the new quantity
okay so that's how you're doing so
number is the verb to count that's what
the word number stands for and we depict
it or illustrate it with a symbol called
a numeral okay so that's what we argue
here but if it's um if it's counting it
ain't measuring because
um County and measuring are two
different uh activities and the problem
we had with the mathematicians is that
they want to include measuring okay and
so they here's an example you know the
complex number system says is an element
of a number system that extends the real
numbers with a specific element denoted
etc etc
irrational numbers uh called imaginary
I'm sorry imaginary numbers uh unit and
satisfying the equation uh et cetera Etc
okay and so they have all these examples
there of what an imaginary number is
and the question is is are these numbers
what are these numbers used for and I'm
saying that these numbers are used for
measuring it's got to do with
measurement not at all with County you
cannot count to one and one-third okay
you cannot count to
three-fifths or whatever okay whatever
fraction and you can also uh put that in
terms of
um uh fractions and I'm sorry in in
terms of uh decimals okay because a
decimal point is just that
and so here's the problem that I see
with that see uh the mathematicians
merge numerals with operations and call
them numbers because they have the
numeral okay in this case uh there's an
example there okay uh two-thirds or uh
one end 1.35 okay and the question what
are we staring at well the numeral the
number is two
the two represents the two is a numeral
that represents the number two which is
the quantities that you counted okay you
counted twice and you call that a two
you put a numeral that looks like that
symbol there too and you did the same
thing with the three
and but now you're going to perform an
operation two over three you're going to
divide two into three
and the question is that operation that
you did with these two numerals with
these two quantities with these two
numbers right does is that a number
okay and your mathematician say yes it
is but for that you have to define the
word number correctly so that it fits so
that it includes the operation okay and
so what they did they bunched it all
together and they say well it's all the
same you know numbers uh operations
transactions that you do between numbers
that's also a number because the result
is some kind of could be a fraction
right you have one over one you get one
right but two over two you get one also
right but if you have a fraction like
two-thirds or I don't know one-fifth or
whatever well then you'll get uh the
fraction on the one hand you can turn
that into a decimal which is a different
way of writing the fraction okay and the
issue is that we can't count to a
fraction we can only count units and so
you can see the difference between
counting and measuring because
measurement almost always has to do with
fractions and decimals whereas county is
always units okay the you can say the
integers right and so here's my
criticism fraction is an operation okay
two and three are the numerals in the
example of the above right and the eyes
and the slash is what you do to them
that's an operation you're going to
perform on these two numbers right uh
0.35 again that's a different way of uh
presenting the Frac a fraction any
fraction
um
um uh so we can only count integers
right and we can't count to zero so zero
is not a number
because you can't count zero uh like you
know again like I'm saying uh zero cow
zero threes and zero apples
is all the same okay it's like we don't
care about the unit it's like it's zero
whatever so you can't say that zero is a
number zero is the absence of numbers of
things to count okay so zero we're not
going to include it as a number okay
under our definition which is counting
can't count to zero you can't count to
Infinity
you know uh how long are you gonna live
you're gonna continue counting and and
then when you die you know the numbers
continue it's like you can't count to
Infinity because if Infinity just means
you count forever
until the universe expires or whatever
so no uh you got to keep these things in
mind that the definitions are important
and what the mathematicians never did is
Define okay they're terrible definers
okay they don't know how to define words
scientifically and that's why they get
uh involved in uh in problems uh
afterwards because uh you know they they
run against brick walls they can say
whatever they want because they're using
words of ordinary speech rather than
words which are scientifically defined
okay so here we have um
another uh person another
issue with numbers
are negative numbers numbers
and here we have you know uh negative is
the same thing as positive in a sense
because both involve in operation
positive are not integers see the many
people confuse them because they say
well you don't need to put the plus sign
if it's a positive integer and so they
confuse integers you know with uh
operations which is the plus sign and
likewise they think that negative is
also uh a number because they have this
little this one or the two after the
negative sign but see negative and
positive are operations integers are
just the numbers the you know that
little numeral that represents a number
Okay so
a little different that's why it's
important to keep these things separate
so that we understand them well negative
uh again is a subtraction operation it's
like division square root power ETC
number stands alone without an operation
okay it's the numeral representing the
number the number is
County okay that's what number is uh
numerous assemble numbers to count
okay
so
um under uh my definition where do we
put
uh the word number in our uh Universal
movie Universal movie has the
distinction between Dynamic and static
Concepts static Concepts only take up
one frame in the Universal movie whereas
Dynamic Concepts take up a minimum of
two and usually more in other words
Dynamic Concepts are those that embody
motion whereas static concepts are those
that do not have motion they embody only
location okay distance between objects
we're talking about physics right so uh
it's either a static concept fits in a
single frame of the universal movie or
it involves two or more frames where are
we going to put number well it's the
verb to count where do you think we're
going to put it we're going to put it at
the bottom we're going to put it in the
uh Dynamic concept region because it's
the verb to count number requires at
least two frames of the movie you're
making a comparison also between numbers
I mean if there was only one number in
the world one right for example then uh
it might even have a chance to go in the
static
concept uh region uh you know the upper
part single frame but number uh is you
know you don't only have one number you
have many numbers so number is a
comparison against other numbers that's
one issue and the other one is that you
need to move that finger up and down to
count
that's what number is so yeah number is
a dynamic concept it's not a static
concept but all okay
and uh so here we go with our
conclusions okay we have
um
numbers a dynamic concept okay number is
the verb to count and hopefully counting
is a dynamic uh activity
the verb uh we can't count to zero okay
because there's nothing to count
literally
can't count to Infinity okay because you
won't live that long
uh fraction is an operation
okay and then that's what it's got to do
with measurement okay
negative numbers again also in operation
and a numeral is not the same thing as
number because the numeral is the symbol
you're going to use to represent
Counting okay
what is our corollary well we have
mathematical physics you know the
physicists out there they don't do
arithmetic Reading Writing arithmetic
the three R's okay they don't work with
integers almost almost at all rarely no
they do measurements because they do
experiments and then they do operations
okay they have equations right they use
decimals and fractions okay so the
reason mathematical physicists like the
definition that they have today where
they put everything in there you know
they say numbers everything it includes
the operation it includes zero it
includes Infinity includes all these
things in there some some of them don't
they say zero and infinity are not
others say yes so they have these
debates they and again because they
don't Define what a number is because if
they Define it as counting you can't
count to zero and you can't count to
Infinity so those two are taken off okay
off the record now you can only count uh
integers so that eliminates negative
signs fractions Etc and so yeah it's the
mathematical physicists physicists and
quotations right uh those are the ones
who want to include the word measurement
in their meaning fractions why because
they want to do operations and they want
to include
the word number together with an
operation call that whole thing a number
which is actually a result of an
operation okay because what is
two-thirds two-thirds is a fraction
decimal if you you're going to use 0.66
Etc but the point here is that if if
you're going to use two-thirds what
you're looking at is the result of that
operation so we instantly say what's
what is two-thirds well it's 0.66 right
or two-thirds you know it's not a unit
it's two-thirds is a fraction of a unit
and why because you've already performed
an operation what you did is you cut the
table uh by one-third you say I have
two-thirds of a table two-thirds of a
tree or whatever right two-thirds of a
rock so you performed an operation and
two over three is an operation okay so
they're looking at the result and that's
what they do in mathematical physics
physics they carry out experiments out
there measurements observations whatever
they call them uh predictions and a
represent their calculations in the form
of decimals usually you know rarely very
rarely do you get to an integer today
that's why you know mathematical physics
is
[Music]
um
outside the bounds of arithmetic which
deals primarily or exclusively I mean uh
with integers whereas mathematics
includes the whole shebang you know they
do operations in they put everything and
they call them numbers okay and what is
the number according to now it's a
mathematical object which is a concept
which is an abstraction
which is a concept which is an
abstraction because
all in a circular way and so you never
find out what they're talking about
that's why they can't Define what
mathematics is about right
okay and let's move on to some of the
questions people ask some of the issues
they raised okay give me a second here
clean some of this up okay you have one
fellow and he says all the energy
released from radioactive reactions are
just atoms getting separated from the
big molecules
those very special
radioactive molecules have so much rope
tension in them that when even a single
atom splits there is such a huge tension
release that all the atoms around get
moving faster hence there is a big
energy input into the system is that
about right uh nine
next
no it's not so energy splitting uh
removing one or more atoms out of a
molecule and a release tension moves uh
stuff around and it can be utilized by
machines am I thinking correctly well
not under the Rope model okay so let's
get it right
to make sure what a nuclear reaction is
according to Quantum and according to
the Rope model we have two models
totally different okay here you have the
quantum model okay and what you're
staring at on the left hand side is you
have a
something that hits the atoms breaks or
the uh like in this case uranium atoms
it breaks them apart okay and so you
have uh the neutrons going in One
Direction uh protons in another and this
explosion of matter because you're
talking about atoms here right on the
Left End time we're talking about atoms
you're breaking them up in that uh chain
reaction is what causes you know the uh
this explosion it's uh it's that is the
explosion there
the problem we have is really on the
right hand side and that's the energy
that's released that's what they call it
energy and what is that well that's
radiation they use all these synonyms
and they never knew what these things
are what is that light that's coming out
of the ground zero that's the issue okay
and so this is the version that
um that quantum mechanics has okay we
have a little electron bead that's
rolling around the atom and it falls and
Rises uh to and from energy levels okay
so that's that's the uh way they present
it in other words they say the electron
is a little bead when it falls it
releases energy when it rises it absorbs
energy okay so that's that's what this
is all about
and so what is the problem here the
problem is uh that we have with this
model is that it doesn't explain why the
electron B doesn't spontaneously just
lead the atom why doesn't the atom
ionize spontaneously and or if you
rather look at it the other way which is
how this model came about why didn't the
electron fall all the way to the nucleus
after all the electron is alleged to be
negative and the nucleus is supposed to
be positive positive attracts negative
there should be no reason whatsoever for
the electron not to fall to the center
of the atom to the nucleus to where the
proton is okay it doesn't for some
reason that they cannot explain and they
never did
you know uh they cannot explain why that
negative electron doesn't fall to the
center of the atom and then at the same
time you don't know why it doesn't
spontaneously leave and ionize the atom
so that's what we have the problem we
have with the so-called energy released
uh the Rays uh radiation light
electromagnetism I don't care the word
or the term that you use that stuff that
comes out of the atom waves okay they
cannot tell you what it is and so they
use all these synonyms and they say yes
waves it's energy it's radiation and we
never know what they because those are
all Concepts so far we have no object is
light
that thing that comes out this energy
this radiation is that a physical object
or not what is that
and so when you have this explosion with
a nuclear explosion not only do you have
atoms that come out like you know if you
look at the uranium atom it's got 92
hydrogen atoms right and 200 plus
neutrons they're all crunching it's a
big atom compared to you know hydrogen
atom and so it's it's really releasing
hydrogen atoms that's what it is it's
exploding the uranium atom is shedding
its skin so to speak but in the process
it's also expelling radiation and the
issue is what is that radiation is that
matter
what is that stuff
that's the issue okay so we don't have a
problem with the the little balls coming
out of the uranium atom you know
disintegrating somewhere that's no
problem we agree with that okay we have
no problem there uh the issue is the
radiation okay and so here I can only
give you my version the Rope hypothesis
okay this is the basic model this is
what
um uh Quantum jump is we call it quantum
pumping because the atom is really
pumping torsion waves to other atoms you
have the 2D version the 3D version okay
and so what it's doing it's uh the
electron is not a little bead that rolls
around the atom it's a membrane that
encapsulates the atom now we now we can
see why it spontaneously jumps between
so-called energy levels because it just
jumps between the energy levels because
it is Quantum Jumping it's pumping it's
going back and forth and by doing so it
tors the the rope that interconnects it
to any other atom in the universe all
atoms in the universe are interconnected
okay so that's how we visualize not only
the atom but Quantum Jumping okay it's a
little more elaborate than this but this
is just the basics okay okay so if this
is our atom then how do we explain
um
uh the release of energy the release of
uh this thing they call radiation
electromagnetism waves all these
synonyms that they use that they cannot
or never will be able to explain well
we're saying this is the atom the atom
there uh at the lower left hand corner
that's where the center of the atom is
the nucleus okay and you have these
single lines which uh are going to form
the proton okay it's a bunch of single
lines these lines are the threads and
that when they twine around with the
thread coming out of the electron shell
which is uh that curve that you see
there in red they form the rope that
comes out of the atom okay so the atom
is uh you can see the electron shell is
pumping back and forth okay see it here
again okay you can see the electron cell
is going back and forth by doing so it
torques the rope that connects it to any
other atom in the universe and that
torsion that goes along the Rope is what
we call Energy radiation or whatever
so when you have a nuclear explosion
okay not only do you break up a big atom
like the Uranus uranium atom but you're
releasing all this
um radiation which are torsions along
every single row from every atom in the
universe from every atom in the universe
connected to your atom to one atom one
hydrogen atom that means what uh big
atom like uh uh uranium has 92 protons
92 electrons well they're just uh
hydrogen atoms which are merged with
each other each one has one rope to
every atom in the universe including to
those
that form the uranium atom so when that
atom that is expelled with that hydrogen
atom that proton and
electron shell is expelled there's also
a release of so-called energy meaning
that you have torsions along the rows
that interconnects every one of those
atoms to every atom in the universe
okay so that's the process we're
suggesting it's got nothing to do with
little beads discrete beads that roll
around for no reason around the nucleus
don't fall into the nucleus don't
spontaneous the ionis uh leave the the
nucleus that's what you got to explain
if you can't explain that you haven't
explained anything in Quantum in 100
years has not been able to explain that
they do a lot of math but they cannot
explain the mechanism that's the issue
okay okay so here we have an another
question Paula says
you still don't get it Bill uh okay I
have given you plenty of mechanism but
you still don't understand he's talking
about The Ether right what you call a
description was an example of what
gravity is the air is analog to The
Ether The Ether is ubiquitous I have
given you a full explanation no no uh
until you define The Ether you have not
said anything absolutely nothing you
need if you're going to use the ether
tell us what the ether is and there's
only two ways it's either an object or a
concept there's no other possibility
every word in the dictionary falls under
objects that which has shape or under
concept
quick way is that which doesn't have
shape the uh more elaborate way is that
it's a relation between two objects okay
and so here you have it if it's an
object draw it point to it show us what
what you're talking about when you say
ether okay and the guy doesn't want to
do that because he's going to he can't
figure it out he doesn't know what the
theater is he just said That's The Ether
like if we know what he was talking
about okay so if it's a thing if it's an
object draw it or point to it somewhere
on the internet show us what you're
talking about what it looks like okay if
it's a concept Define it like you would
Define any word okay so the ball is in
your court okay Define don't whine okay
do a lot of whining but you got to do
defining okay okay so here we have
um uh Two Fellas who already said that
they can't live without The Ether okay
and so they put it on the record and
they were both Nobel prizes or one still
is right and when it's good old lining
okay and Einstein said look you know um
um we can't live without The Ether and
he said that in uh 1920 uh dissertation
he gave at the University of Leiden and
he says we may say that according to the
general theory of relativity space is
endowed with physical qualities in this
sense right therefore there exists an
ether according to the general theory of
relativity space without ether is
Unthinkable
then we have them uh Laughlin he got the
Nobel Prize in 1998 and he says the
modern concept of the vacuum of space
confirmed every day by experiment is a
relativistic ether but we don't call it
that because it is taboo so the word
ether has been wiped out but the word
ether means the same thing as space-time
means the same thing as the false vacuum
or whatever the space whatever the audio
synonyms that they use okay yeah it's
The Ether we've never gotten rid of The
Ether in mathematical physics since the
days of the Greeks but then we need to
know what is The Ether what is this
ether that they talk about what has it
been all these hundreds of years and
that's why all these people they're
ignorant because they don't go out there
and do research they they start talking
they say oh because we move The Ether
here like if we knew what they were
talking about no no first understand
what the ether is then you can use the
ethernet discussion right now these
people don't understand what the ether
is so we have to illustrate them for
Illustrated form you look up the word
ether just do a Google search under
images okay and this is where all these
people
illustrate uh obviously a little
different one from the other okay they
have all these different ideas what the
ether is and I don't know which which of
those is The Ether that this fellow
talks about okay so first we need to
know what the ether is what do you mean
by the word ether what do you mean every
time you use the word ether
and so for this we need to educate him
so let's educate them and all the people
who propose The Ether so that these
people understand what they're talking
about if they don't like this definition
very simple you define it or if you
think it's an object point to it but
don't tell me I'm wrong and then I don't
know what the ether is okay I'm wrong
I'll I'll admit it I'm wrong I don't
know what the ether is okay please tell
me what the ether is don't say that I'm
wrong and then continue just talking
about The Ether no Define or illustrate
okay and here it is okay these people
will educate you luminiferous ether the
postulated medium for the propagation of
light it was invoked to explain the
ability of the Apparently wave-based
light to propagate through empty space
vacuum right something that waves should
not be able to do the Assumption of a
spatial plenum of laminiferous ether
rather than a spatial vacuum provided
the theoretical medium right that was
required by wave theories of light so
you need a medium if you're going to
talk about waves right
says in the 17th century Robert Boyle
The Ether consists of subtle particles a
diffused and very subtle substance those
are his exact words okay and Christian
Huggins you know treaty online uh on
light uh he said hypothesize that light
is a wave propagating through an ether
propagating like sound out of sound
propagate well through particles without
particles there ain't no sound you don't
have sound in outer space so what is The
Ether bunch of particles and other
mechanical waves in fluids what's a
fluid made out of particles okay right
that's the way we have it today then
Isaac Newton contended that light is
made up of numerous what small particles
what is The Ether bunch of particles
that's the scientific definition of The
Ether bunch of particles you don't like
it then tell us what you say is The
Ether what what is the definition of The
Ether what are you talking about okay
either Define or Draw
point to a picture illustrate if it's an
object otherwise Define don't whine
don't tell me I'm wrong that I don't
know what the ether is tell us what it
is
okay that's the way it works
okay so here it is here's the ether okay
bunch of particles that's the definition
of The Ether
that's what you've been talking about
for the last two thousand years more uh
we're talking about even the Greeks
right so that's either a bunch of
particles that's what they always
thought and uh this is what it looks
like okay so you know
That's The Ether a bunch of particles
and when they wave up and down those
particles produce waves that's the uh
notion that they had that's what they
were looking for in the 19th century uh
Michelson and Morley 1887 okay so they
were looking at this they were saying
look there seems to be an ether out
there and they ran a test and they said
there ain't no ether light travels in
this in at the same speed in any
direction and that was uh impossible in
their in under the Newtonian point of
view because you know if you have the uh
if if you have the train and the light
on the train and you point the um uh you
know the uh Collide it forward in the
direction of the train you have to add
the speed of light to the speed of the
tree and that wasn't so with light they
were able to measure that and they said
look that's not the case light travels
at the same speed in every direction why
the only way you can expand it under the
Rope model then you can explain it
because why if every atom is connected
to all other atoms in the universe all
you have is a torsion along the rope and
the atom eats into the Rope as it moves
along the Rope slides along it because
the atom itself is made of the two
threads of the threads right that make
up the ropes
so only then can you explain why the
train speed is not added to the speed of
light because every atom of the train is
simply eating into the roads that
connect it to whatever your uh to
whatever the flashlight is connected to
as well all the light is mediated by
some kind of physical entity we say it
looks like a rope a pair of twine
threads okay then you can explain it but
these Notions that people have that
waves and particles you know they you
cannot explain it with discrete
particles you cannot explain light you
cannot explain gravity attraction how do
you how do you attract particles right
so this is the issue not only that you
have uh the grand unified theory because
if if you have uh ropes connected
connecting what we call ropes
electromagnetic ropes a pair of twine
threads DNA electrics right if you have
every atom connected by these twined
pair of threads here we have a model
okay that's what it looks like or like a
rope my fists are the atoms right and
then what you have is torsion okay okay
so if you have this now you can explain
gravity because now you have a medium
and so you're not talking about action
at a distance it's just that we can't
see or touch the mediator the Rope
that's all that was all that we had to
figure out in these Ten Thousand Years
okay so here we have um
the conclusion uh ether is an object or
a concept that's what you got to tell me
if it's an object draw it if it's a
constant defining don't line you do a
lot of whining
okay no whining okay we need definitions
okay and uh last fella here he also
raised a similar issue it's got to do
with the slit experiment and he says the
phone says light is not a wave aha I
totally agree why because light waves
are mathematical abstraction absolutely
he's totally right it's a mathematical
abstraction what what are you staring at
you're staring at you know when you look
at I should have brought that up there
but what you're staring at is vectors
each one of those arrows in the
electromagnetic wave right Maxwell's
wave is one of those vectors what is
that what is a vector it's magnitude and
Direction so you had some mathematical
concept that's all the wave is it's not
a physical object I can't bring a wave
to the conference and say look this is a
way
you know what am I going to bring like a
fish with his scales say this is a wave
all the bones there
there is no harmine uh that's uh you
know this Naseem haramin hermine uh
Quantum Consciousness BS either
absolutely uh haramine never hit it on
the nose because he he's talking about
nonsense he's talking about
Consciousness
um keeping uh all atoms interconnected
and he also talks about energy so now
you can't connect physically connect
objects with Concepts such as
Consciousness or energy so that's where
his uh proposal dies so he's right there
as well the double slit experiment huh
that's what he's that's what I was going
to try to explain he says uh pure
assumption without any evidence
in science assumptions do not require
any evidence whatsoever an assumption is
an assumption uh you have to take it for
granted in order to understand the
theory we require no evidence evidence
is what you use to convince persuade the
jury convert them recruit them we don't
do that in science so the word evidence
is unscientific don't not bring it into
the discussion okay the pattern on the
wall comes from Individual strands of
diffracted light
strands I like that sounds like my
theory you know strands yeah elongated
strands right looks like this I guess
but the guy says no following the
following video settles it once and for
all okay so um we go to that video he
gives us a name of the video and we went
there and it's what we find okay we find
this and there's a paper attached to it
so we looked at the paper as well and
this is what the guy shows uh well he
shows quite a bit you can look at it in
the uh uh in YouTube he's got this video
it says double slit experiment
visualization of three space reveals
light strands not waves absolutely
in agreement right strands but this is
where the guy fails miserable he says
novel visualization of light strands
supports the particle theory of light
and provides an alternative to wave
theory
oh man he says consistent with particles
not waves well there we have a little
bit of a difference because you cannot
produce a strand with particles and
that's it one issue and the other one is
that waves are particles made of
particles what do you think waves are
made of uh you know they they always
visualize that as being The Ether and
what was The Ether we just showed you
you know it's a waving of a bunch of
particles so wave theory is a particle
theory okay the it's except that they
don't travel straight they move up and
down what moves them up and down well
that's for God to tell you because
nobody can explain that at all what
pulls each one of those particles up
what pulls it down again that's what we
can't figure out uh with discrete
particles and with discrete particles
you cannot explain anything you
certainly cannot explain gravity and you
cannot even explain light and uh the way
we do it uh show that that's the case
okay
let me show you here uh we have the slit
experiment and you can see the Slither
experiment on the left is the one with
particles the one on the right is the
one with ropes okay every atom is
interconnected in the on the right hand
side so what happens well when you
remove the slit and you put instead a
needle like I always do okay uh what
does the uh what what does the particle
Ricochet against in other words when you
have the slits then you can argue you
can make a theory that it hits the
border the edge of the slit right and uh
the what is it the uh
uh the seal the window sill right hits
the frame and it bounces inwards you can
explain that with particles okay you can
conceptualize that and say look it hits
the frame goes inwards but when you use
the needle you get rid of the slid you
put a needle there which is what I'm
going to do there you can see it okay
now what does it hit against
okay it doesn't hit against anything
should go straight there should be no
interference pattern so you cannot
explain the slit experiment with
particles on the other hand in our case
uh we're saying all the atoms are
interconnected before you even turn on
the light
they're already connected physically
connected all you're doing with when you
turn on the light is you're increasing
the frequency along each rope to every
atom in the room okay and then yes you
can explain interference because you
have the atoms on the edge of the needle
that are connected to every atom in the
uh on the screen okay where the fringes
appear okay so yeah we can explain with
a rope model these people cannot explain
with particles so when this individual
says that it's a settled issue yeah it's
settled that particles cannot explain
the slit experiment at all that's what's
settled okay it's it's a done deal they
could never explain it with particles
that's why Quantum party quantum
mechanics says that a particle can be at
two places at once because that's the
only way you can explain the slider
experiment with particles and of course
that requires irrationality total
irrationality
okay so here um
we have uh you can look up my uh video
it's got that as the uh icon there uh
for you to look at and there's the link
so you'll see why you cannot explain the
slit experiment with particles or with
waves for that matter waves again like
this fellow said there's no such thing
as a wave wave is a mathematical
object yeah they caught yeah you cannot
explain what ways partly because waves
are particles that's what waves are
they're particles loose particles they
don't know why they vibrate up and down
they just say they do that's why wave is
a uh
it doesn't belong in physics okay there
is it's not a noun it's a verb wave is
what particles do not what they are
okay and so if you look up that video
you'll find uh my version of the slit
experiment okay and uh yeah we have an
experiment
that does away completely with particles
all together and but that's subject
matter for another day okay